I don't know how much you talk about it
in the book but how it did things with
Josh finally end
did you end things what was the final
straw so it definitely wasn't a clean
break with Josh we were on and off for a
while after we after we first broke up
so did it just peter out how did it
finally get to a place where you weren't
in a relationship you weren't talking
anymore to be honest there was a time he
he we were it was back and forth and it
was very like gray area we kind of he's
accepted some dating app Instagram deal
and I was like if you do that I'm out
and then I ended up going on paradise
like a few months later would you
recommend any more reality TV for him I
don't know whatever he wants to do but
there wasn't a thing I don't know if you
saw this like over the past couple weeks
of him allegedly hooking up with another
reality TV star one of the Chris leaves
I had it sent to me yeah I don't even
know what that what it's about okay wait
a second
Oh oh my what a little crazy utterly
just hit me yes it's both of your exes
Amanda I don't know anything about it
okay but I had multiple people send it
to me obviously cuz they think it was
posted online and I had people sending
me the article being like oh my god
what's this and I was like hey no idea
yeah so well Rob he's gone on to date
someone from Vanderpump rules do you
keep in touch with Robbie and is he in
the book at all there is a part about
Robbie in the book too because they kind
of go I kind of go over on my all my
relationships over the past few years so
there's definitely a part about Rafi in
there too yeah
what can we expect cuz I remember you
guys had quite a breakup after paradise
on that that after-show yeah to be
honest it's not - we didn't really date
for very long so there's a little small
part in there about Robbie but just a
couple like behind the scenes things
that I don't think I've never talked
about that I think will be pretty
interesting I don't want to give away
too much but yeah yeah are you surprised
when someone sends you a link about
Robbie and Josh being involved in a sex
tape scandal with another reality star
honestly nothing surprises me anymore so
yeah but that did not that did not spray
you to reach out in text better and
yeah yeah yeah I think actually Robbie
said today he went on a podcast and said
that it was a dog cam right yeah
essentially I was like anything on
better terms with Josh of Robbie it's
hard for me I would say probably Josh
okay yeah and you guys did have a more
in-depth relationship yes okay so I know
him better so it's like you know no
matter what happens in relation if you
have those you know you cared about that
person at one point I think I think I
have a little more respect for Josh
Robbie